one movie that a lot of people are
talking about that's having its big
premiere here world premiere in fact is
the Martian directed by ridley scott
starring matt damon i'm hearing people
say its gravity meets interstellar we've
all seen it I kind of like that
mathematical equation it does have
pieces of that no it wasn't at all it's
like castaway mates a beautiful mind in
a way because of the science that's go
with me here and then also has a lot of
humor as well I love the book by Andy
weir and so I was so excited to see it
on the big screen I know you were I saw
you at the screening I know and I wasn't
sure if it was just me liking the book
that made it such a great experience but
you loved it as well yeah and I hadn't
read the book cuz I'm a slow reader and
it's just thick and it was gonna happen
to me but no I was riveted and that's
the thing about it is how many actors
could you watch on screen by him or
herself I think Matt Damon is one of the
few along with let's say Tom Hanks or
Sandra Bullock that can really hold the
screen with humor and seriousness he
brings all about to the role you really
loved it I love this movie it's already
one of my favorite movies in the year
and exactly what you were saying this is
everything that people love about Matt
Damon and one roll the action hero the
nerd you know the charismatic funny man
like everything you love about this guy
is racked up in this you roll it in a
seat does it just great and there's so
much about this movie I was speaking to
someone actually at fandango about how
empowering it is also for little kids
and who love math and science because it
just it's Sciences out big time in this
film and it's nerdy but it's funny and I
was crying at the end she's got
everything it does make it cool to be a
geek right and the best news of all is
that we've all seen it but it does come
out on october second so get your
tickets on fandango and check out the
Martian thanks guys talk to you soon
you